i would say before you do that
understand how distribution works
because once you understand how you make
your money back
then you can justify how much money you
spend
can you talk about the decision that you
were not going to make movies by
committee anymore and what does that
mean
it's
for me it's it's it's about it's going
back to accountability and
being able to hold myself accountable
for for not growing for not achieving
the level of growth that i need to
achieve
when you're making a movie by committee
which i understand completely that most
industry movies are made by when it's
you know a studio or whatever
but
going through that many
levels of decision making and
you know this person believes they know
what's better for the film they know
what's better for the audience they know
what's better for marketing they know
i believe you need one voice
we need one voice
that ultimately makes the decision of
what to do inside of the film you can
definitely confer with everyone around
you when i hire an actor i hire them
because they are the best at what they
do and they fit this role and when they
read the script they're going to be able
to tell me
things to a level of detail that maybe i
haven't thought about right and i trust
their intuition and i'm going to figure
out a way where we can kind of make that
work inside the film but that's not what
i mean by committee what i mean by
committee is
a
executive producer who now says you know
what and this is a real thing that
happened
yeah i think we need a topless scene
right now
and how there's
in what way you know it's like at what
time would somebody take their clothes
off that doesn't even make any sense
there's a murderer running around and
everybody's in the same room
like what would be the reason that they
would need to you know it's like a lot
of those decisions that are just made
because
people want to be heard and they want to
see whatever they've said show up on the
film it's a vanity
and ultimately when you're making movies
like that and by committee with multiple
people having all of this input your
film is getting further and further and
further away from what you're trying to
achieve and as i said the only person
i'm really competing with is the person
that i was yesterday i'm constantly
trying to grow and how can i measure my
growth if
everything around me is being affected
by people who are not me
and people who've already articulated
that
it has to be in there or
you know basically they can withdraw
funding that's ultimately what it is is
that the decisions when they're being
made by committee are made by people who
can ultimately make the decision of if
you won't do what i'm asking you to do
if you won't put this in the film
i can withdraw funding and i can do it
at any time i can do it at any point
because again
they're not as invested in the film as
you are they're invested in their own
vanity a lot of times not not all the
times there are some great financers out
there and some great executive producers
but unfortunately i haven't worked with
them
you know but the ones that i've worked
with have been
kind of vein and and it has been the
vanity of having whatever was in their
head added to the film even if it
doesn't make sense
story-wise
sure and and
in any relationship where someone's
giving you money they they kind of own
you in a sense they do they do and
especially when you know that they can
pull the plug and it's the reason why i
have overlooked a lot of the things that
have been done on the set you have to
let a lot of things go
and try to control the things you can
control
um
but
along the way
this committee will continuously try to
in influence everything that you do and
it makes your personal growth
and measure you can't measure it because
it's not really you it's you plus that
guy and that lady and that kid you know
it's it's you plus all of this when it
should be you
making the sole decision now you can
take
inspiration from what other people say
you can take
some advice from what other people say
if it applies if it's applicable but you
can ultimately decide if it's not
and i only begin to get that sense of
freedom when i started to
to finance my own projects
that's when i began to see it
what kind of sacrifices did you have to
make to be able to finance your own work
um
security
financial security oh yeah for a while
for a while um financial security um
a lot of things that
probably so many to to too many to name
but things that would have certainly
made uh
my young lady happy um we had to
sacrifice a lot with the sacrifice
a lot of time that you would normally
spend together i was holed up by myself
doing so many things myself because
whatever you can't pay for you have to
assume that responsibility yourself
so even when we would be sacrificing
financially
um we were also sacrificing just the
time we got to spend together and it was
it was very hard time in the beginning a
very hard time
um but here's the thing is
and i don't advise that people just run
out and start self-financing their own
stuff i i would say before you do that
understand how distribution works
because once you understand how you make
your money back
then you can justify how much money you
spend on a project
right you don't want to give yourself
you don't want to take you know a loan
out for eighty thousand dollars hundred
thousand dollars and make a movie that
you're only going to make five thousand
dollars from you need to stack as many
of the of the statuses stack as much of
the deck in your favor as possible
so but you know in the beginning i
certainly had to sacrifice financial
security and i had to sacrifice a lot of
time
and
spend a lot of time away
from my lady you know uh and i've been
away from my family since 2004. i go
back home every once in a while to
georgia but for the most part
my family has seen me on average maybe
once every three years till maybe maybe
every two years but i probably lean
towards the three i don't go home that
often
so
there's been a lot of sacrifice to get
to where i am today
and when you're writing a script
is it now in your mind
that okay this is going to cost too much
and i'm not going to make my money back
on this i have to change this scene
no i i'm always aware of the story that
i'm writing and
the budget that it falls within
i make sure i tell the truth in the
story
and
budget should never dictate truth
but budget should dictate what you're
trying to do as a whole i don't think
you should make a sci-fi opera if you
only have two thousand dollars i i think
that that's a that's setting yourself up
for for failure i think that if you're
gonna tell
a
very intimate story between two
characters that
you know they met outside of a motel
you know in the parking lot
and they're developing this romance over
two days at the motel and one guy is
there on a business trip and the lady
lives there yeah whatever but if you're
trying to make something very small
and
mostly just the conversations that they
have between one another and those
that's easy to do and that's very
inexpensive but if one of them is a
cybernetic organism and they shapeshift
and uh they walk they walk through these
wormholes that constantly open up and
now all the machines are coming out to
attack everybody and the motel blows up
then i think you've kind of set yourself
up for
for
for failure